Hai, de wa, lesson hachi (8) no saisho no
hajime no kanji desu keredo mo, mazu, kono
kanji, imi wa Ôeffect,Ő to ka Ôbe effectiveŐ
to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, part nan desu keredo mo, component.
Kono hidarigawa no kono component, kono part
wa desu ne, ÔexchangeŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ÔkŘryu,Ő Ôexchange.Ő
Sore kara, Ôkokusai kŘryu,Ő Ôinternational
exchangeŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Sore kara, kono migigawa.
Kore wa mŘ minna shittemasu yo ne. Ôpower,Ő
ÔchikaraŐ to iu imi desu.
So if you exchange your power, you can be
more effective to iu, de, kono kanji, ÔeffectŐ
to ka ÔeffectiveŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading ga
main desu.
ÔkŘŐ to iimasu.
Tatoeba, ÔkŘka,Ő Ôresult.Ő
Sore kara ÔkŘritsu,Ő Ôefficiency.Ő
Sore kara ÔyđkŘ,Ő kore wa na adjective
desu keredo mo, ÔeffectiveŐ to iu adjective
desu.
Ato, ÔyakkŘ,Ő kono kanji wo mitara dŘ
deshŘ ka?
Kore wa Ôkusuri,Ő Ômedicine.Ő
Sore kara Ôeffect,Ő dakara ÔyakkŘŐ
tte iu no wa, sono, nan desu ka, Ôdrag effectŐ
to iu yŘ na imi desu.
Ato kun reading de ÔkikuŐ to iu no ga
arimasu.
Ôkiku.Ő
Ôkusuri ga kikuŐ so Ômedicine worked.
EffectiveŐ to iu imi desu.
Hai, de wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa Ôdivision,Ő
sore kara Ôsubject of studyŐ to iu imi
ga arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo, mazu kono
hidarigawa, kono radical, kore wo ÔnogihenŐ
to iimasu.
Imi wa desu ne ÔgrainŐ to iu imi desu.
Sore kara hidarigawa.
Kono kanji wa we used to use this kanji as
a counter which is like 18 liters, but we
no longer use this counter.
But you can imagine a story you need some
sort of counter or cup, in order to divide
grains.
De, yomikata desu keredo mo, kore wa on reading
dake de daijŘbu desu.
Tatoeba, Ôgakuka,Ő Ôcourse of subject.Ő
ÔKamoku,Ő Ôsubject of study.Ő
Sore kara Ôkagaku.Ő
Chotto koko kiwotsukete kudasai.
Kono kagaku wa Ôscience.Ő
Kore mo Ôkagaku,Ő both are read as Ôkagaku,Ő
but this character means Ôchemistry.Ő
Sore kara Ônaika,Ő Ôinternal medicine.Ő
Ôgeka,Ő Ôsurgical department.Ő
Hai, de wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ÔdecreaseŐ no imi ga
arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo, kono radical
daijŘbu desu ne, Ôwater.Ő
Sore kara, kono part desu keredo mo, kore
wa you can imagine like weapon or spear, so
something like someone is actually making
a hole with a weapon so that the water decreases.
Ma, sono story ga dekiru ka to omoimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading.
Kore wa ÔgenŐ to iimasu.
Tatoeba, ÔgenshŘ,Ő daijŘbu desu ne,
Ôdecrease,Ő soshite Ôsukunaku narimasu,Ő
Ôto decrease.Ő
Ôgenten,Ő kore wa ÔpointŐ to iu imi
desu.
Dakara, Ôto decrease points,Ő Ôreduction,Ő
Ôpoint reductionŐ no koto desu.
Sore kara Ôgensoku.Ő
Kono soku tte iu no wa ÔfastŐ to ka ÔspeedŐ
desu yo ne.
Dakara Ôspeed ga decreaseŐ no imi desu.
Ôgenz•,Ő kore wa Ôz•kin,Ő Ôtax,Ő
so Ôtax reductionŐ no imi desu.
Ato, kun reading de ÔheruŐ to iu yomikata.
ÔheŐ desu. Ôheru.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔjinkŘ ga hetta,Ő Ôthe population
decreasedŐ to iu imi desu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ÔcompleteŐ to iu imi
desu.
Component nan desu keredo mo, kono part, kono
radical wo mitara, kore, think about the meaning
of roof of a house.
So roof.
Sore de, tsugi no kono part nan desu keredo
mo, kore wa, this part, this kanji, character
itself means Ôorigin,Ő to ka ÔbaseŐ
no imi desu.
Tatoeba, Ôgenki,Ő Ôthe origin of your
spirit.Ő
So Ôgenki desu.Ő
De, you can imagine a story so the base was
attached to the roof so the house is completed.
So complete.
Complete no imi desu.
Yomikata desu keredo mo, on reading de Ôkan.Ő
Tatoeba, Ôkans•, kans• shimashita,Ő
Ôcompleted.Ő
Sore kara ÔkanryŘ shimashita,Ő kore mo,
ma, ÔcompleteŐ ariwa ÔfinishŐ no imi
ga arimasu.
Sore kara Ôkanzen,Ő kore wa ÔperfectŐ
no imi desu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa Ôto climb,Ő ÔclimbŐ
no imi ga arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo, kono ue
no part desu yo ne.
Kore wa you can imagine outspreaded legs,
tatoeba, departure no imi ga arimasu.
Yoku tsukau no wa Ôshuppatsu,Ő Ôto depart,Ő
Ôshuppatsu suruŐ desu yo ne, ÔdepartureŐ
no imi desu.
Sore kara, naka no kanji.
Kore wa mame, ÔbeanŐ desu.
So you have to bring beans in order to climb
a high mountain to iu no de, kore dochira
mo kŘ awasete, noboru, Ôclimb,Ő nan desu
keredo mo, Ônoboru.Ő
Tatoeba, Ôfujisan ni noboru.Ő
Particle kore ÔniŐ wo kyŘtsukete kudasai.
Ôto climb.Ő
Sore kara, on reading de desu ne, tatoeba,
ÔtŘzanŐ kore wa Ôyama ni noboru kotoŐ desu.
Sore kara ÔtŘkŘ.Ő
Kore wa gakkŘ no kŘ desu.
Dakara, gakkŘ ni iku koto desu.
Sore kara, ÔtŘjŘŐ kore wa desu ne, tatoeba,
Ôkono geki ni tŘjŘ shimashita,Ő Ôto
appearŐ no imi desu.
Kore wa bashŘ no ba, place no imi desu.
Dakara, sono bashŘ ni itta to iu imi desu,
to appear.
Hai.
Hai. De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa Ôpublic,Ő
sore kara ÔofficialŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, kono kanji, there is no story associated
with this kanji but this is simply just katakana
ha, and katakana mu.
And you can concatenate those two characters.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo,
On reading de ÔkŘ.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔkŘen,Ő kore daijŘbu desu ne,
Ôpark.Ő
Sore kara, ÔkŘritsu daigaku,Ő kore wa
Ôpublic university.Ő
Sore kara, ÔkŘkai suru.Ő
Kore wa Ôto present something to the publicŐ
to iu imi desu.
De, kun reading nan desu keredo mo, amari
tsukaimasen keredo mo, ÔŘyake,Ő to iu
yomikata mo arimasu.
Tatoeba desu ne, Ôsono jiken wo Řyake ni
shita,Ő kore wa, sono jiken wo kŘkai shita
to onaji imi desu.
Hai, de wa, kono kanji desu keredo mo, kanji
no imi wa ÔlowŐ to iu imi desu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo, kono radical
daijŘbu desu yo ne, kore wa Ôhito,Ő ÔpersonŐ
no radical desu.
Sore kara, kono part, kono part desu keredo
mo, kono kanji by itself means ÔtribeŐ
or Ôclan.Ő
So this is the person who is the lowest in
one clan.
Or in some tribe, to iu imi de ÔlowŐ nan
desu ga.
Yomikata, mazu, kun reading de Ôhikui.Ő
DaijŘbu desu ne, Ôse ga hikui desuŐ sore
kara Ôondo ga hikui desu.Ő ÔlowŐ to
iu imi desu. Ôthe temperature is low.Ő
Ôse ga hikui desu,Ő ÔitŐs short,Ő
to iu imi desu.
Sore kara Ôt•,Ő kore wa on reading de
Ôt•on,Ő Ôlow temperature,Ő sore kara
Ôsait•,Ő kore wa Ôthe worstŐ kore
wa Ômotto moŐ no imi desu kara Ôsait•,Ő
Ôthe worst.Ő
Hantai, opposite wa ÔsaikŘ,Ő Ôthe bestŐ
to iu tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji no imi wa desu ne, Ôreverse,Ő
toka ÔcontraryŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, radical, kono component nan desu keredo
mo, kono radical, kono bubun desu yo ne,
Kore wo shinyŘ, shinyđ dochira demo iin
desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔlegsŐ no imi ga
arimasu.
Or something to do with legs.
Tatoeba, chotto kanji no list wo mite kudasai.
Ômichi,Ő Ôstreet.Ő
ÔtŘri,Ő Ôstreet, roadŐ desu yo ne,
Ôchikai, tŘi.Ő
So this is something to do with legs.
Sore kara, you can imagine this person in
a handstand.
So he must be going opposite or reverse.
Sonna story ga daijŘbu ka to omoimasu.
De, yomikata desu keredo mo, on reading de
Ôgyaku.Ő
Tatoeba, Ôgyaku,Ő Ôreverse,Ő aruiwa
Ôopposite.Ő
Sore kara, Ôgyakusetsu.Ő
Setsu tte iu no wa ÔexplanationŐ to ka,
sŘ iu imi ga arun desukedo ÔgyakusetsuŐ
toiunode, Ôparadox.Ő
Sore kara Ôgyakuryđ,Ő Ôcounter current,Ő
kore wa ÔcurrentŐ no imi ga arimasu.
Ato desu ne, amari tsukaimasen keredo mo,
ma, kun reading de Ôsakadachi.Ő
Ôsakadachi wo shite kudasai.Ő
Ôto do handstandŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, kono kanji no imi wa
ÔpointŐ desu.
So kono part nan desu keredo mo
Kono ue no kanji by itself means Ôuranau,Ő
Ôto fortune tellingŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Sore kara, shita no kono radical, kore wa
yoku mitemasu keredo mo, ÔfireŐ to iu
imi ga arimasu.
We donŐt have a good story to make for this
character, but this component, this character,
means fortune telling, and this radical always
means fire.
Yomikata, desu kedo, on reading de ÔtenŐ
to iu yomikata desu.
Tatoeba, Ôten,Ő test no ten.
The score, the point of the exam of the test.
Sore kara Ôtensđ,Ő kore mo points, grade,
test no tensđ, test no ten, kore dochira
mo onaji imi desu.
Sore kara Ôgenten,Ő kore wa ten, Ôpoint
wo herasuŐ deduction of points desu yo ne.
Sore kara Ôketten,Ő kore wa Ôdefect.Ő
Ôano hito no ketten wa yoku hanasu koto
desuŐ sono, nani ka, sono ÔdefectŐ to
iu imi ga arimasu.
Sore kara desu ne, densha nanka de yoku miru
kanji da to omoimasu.
Kore wa Ôshđten,Ő kore wa Ôlast point.Ő
Kore Ôowaru.Ő
So ending point, last point.
Tatoeba, Ôshđten wa TŘkyŘ desuŐ to
iu no wa Ôichiban saigŘ no eki wa TŘkyŘ
desuŐ to iu imi desu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa Ônormal, regularŐ
sore kara ÔalwaysŐ to iu imi nan desu
keredo mo, chotto shita no hŘ kara ikimasu.
Component nan desu ga, kono component, ichiban
shita no tokoro desu keredo mo, you can imagine
some banner or flag to iu no de, ma, imi toshite
wa something to do with cloth.
Sore kara tsugi no kono mannaka no, kore wa
daijŘbu desu yo ne, mouth.
So you can imagine, under normal circumstances
you always have to wear a mask.
So this is perfect for our pandemic period.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo,
On reading de ÔjŘŐ to iu no ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ÔjyŘji,Ő kore wa ÔitsumoŐ
to iu imi desu.
Sore kara ÔjŘshiki,Ő kono shiki tte iu
no wa ÔknowledgeŐ to ka ÔsenseŐ to
iu imi ga arun desu kedo, jŘshiki, common
sense.
Sore kara ÔijŘna,Ő kore wa ÔalwaysŐ
nan desu keredo mo, kore wa Ônot,Ő to
iu, ÔdifferentŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
So Ôabnormal.Ő
Sore kara ÔhijŘshikiŐ kore no negative
desu.
So Ôlack of common sense.Ő
Ato desu ne, hijŘni, tte iu no wa, ÔtotemoŐ
to iu imi desu yo ne. ÔhijŘ ni samui desuŐ
ÔkyŘ wa hijŘ ni samui desu.Ő ÔkyŘ
wa totemo samui desuŐ to onaji imi desu.
Ato yoku, tatemono no naka de ÔhijŘguchiŐ
to iu no wo mimasu.
Kore wa Ôemergency exitŐ to iu imi desu.
Ato, kun reading de Ôtsune niŐ kore wa
ÔitsumoŐ to iu, ÔalwaysŐ to iu imi desu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ÔcopyŐ to iu imi ga
arimasu.
De, kono kanji I donŐt have a story, but
this one, kyŘtsukete kudasai.
ThereŐs no dot on top of this.
Sore kara this part, this kanji itself means
ÔataeruŐ to give no imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, kore Ôsha,Ő
on reading de Ôsha.Ő
Tatoeba, minna yoku shitteiru, Ôshashin.Ő
Ôshashin wo totte kudasai.
Shashin wo torimasu.Ő
Ato, Ôshahon suru,Ő kore wa ÔhonŐ
desu yo ne, dakara, Ôto hand-copy a book.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔbukkyŘ no oshie wo shahon shimasuŐ
to ka.
Ato, Ôfukusha suru,Ő kore Ôto copyŐ
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ato, kun reading.
Kore de Ôutsusu.Ő
Kore mo ma, Ôto copyŐ nan desu keredo
mo, Ôtomodachi no notebook wo utsushimasu,Ő
Ôto copy a friendŐs notebook, note,Ő
to iu imi desu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa ÔtrueŐ to
ka ÔgenuineŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Chotto component wo mite mimashŘ.
Kono ichiban ue, ii desu ne, Ôjyđ,Ő Ôten,Ő
sore kara, kore, Ôme,Ő Ôeyes,Ő so
ten eyes are standing on the podium to find
out the truth.
To find out whatŐs really going on.
De, kono kanji Ôtrue,Ő sore kara ÔgenuineŐ
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata desu keredo mo, on reading de ÔshinŐ
to iu yomikata wo shimasu.
Tatoeba, ÔshashinŐ kore wa Ôtruth wo
copyŐ wo suru, ma, Ôphoto, photographŐ
desu keredo mo, Ôshashin wo toru.Ő
Sore kara ÔshinjitsuŐ kore Ôtruth.Ő
Sore kara ÔshinmiŐ Ôreal intention.Ő
Kore wa Ôintention,Ő Ôimi.Ő
Shinmi de real intention desu.
Sore kara, kun reading de ÔmaŐ to iu yomikata
wo shimasu.
Kore wa Ômannaka,Ő Ôright in the middle.Ő
Sore kara Ômasshiro,Ő Ôreally white.Ő
Sore kara ÔmaueŐ Ôright above.Ő
Ômasshita,Ő Ôright under.Ő
SŘ iu tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa Ôcertain,
verifiedŐ no imi ga arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo mazu kono
ichiban hidari no tokoro kore wa Ôstone.Ő
Sore kara kono part nan desu keredo mo this
part has something to do with a bird.
So you can make a story saying that make sure,
verify, that this bird can be safe by putting
a protection, or a roof, and then putting
a stone on the left.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading
de Ôkaku.Ő
Tatoeba, Ôkakujitsu naŐ kore na adjective
desu. Ôcertain.Ő
Sore kara ÔkakuritsuŐ kore wa sđgaku,
math, de yoku tsukaimasu yo ne Ôprobability.Ő
Sore kara Ôm•kaku naŐ kore mo na adjective
desu.
Ôclear,Ő tatoeba Ôm•kaku na setsum•,Ő
Ôclear explanationŐ wo shite kudasai.
Ôs•kaku naŐ kore Ôaccurate.Ő
Sore kara Ôkakushin suruŐ kore wa Ôto
believe firmly.Ő
Sore kara Ôkakunin suruŐ Ôto confirm.Ő
Yoku Ôjikan wo kakunin shite kudasai,Ő
Ôplease confirm the timeŐ konna tsukaikata
wo shimasu.
Ato, kun reading de Ôtashi,Ő ÔtashikameruŐ
Ôto verify.Ő
Tatoeba, Ôjikan wo tashikamete kudasai.Ő
Ma, Ôplease verify the timeŐ to iu imi
desu.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, lesson hachi no saigŘ no, last
character desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔvillageŐ
no imi ga arimasu.
Component, kore daijŘbu desu yo ne, Ôtree.Ő
Sore kara, kono migigawa nan desu keredo mo,
kono kanji, we used to have a counter called
Ôsun,Ő which more directly corresponds
to English ÔinchŐ but you can think about
the meaning like Ôchop off.Ő
So in order to build a village, you have to
chop off lots of trees to iu imi, sonna imi desu.
De, reading nan desu keredo mo, on reading
de Ôson.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔnŘsonŐ kore wa Ôfarm, farm
village.Ő
Sore kara ÔgyosonŐ kore wa Ôfishing
villageŐ
Ato, kun reading de ÔmuraŐ Ôvillage.Ő
And sore kara ÔmurabitoŐ kore Ôvillager.Ő
Mura no hito to iu imi desu.